- So the NRA, the
National Rifle Association
has filed for bankruptcy,
but before you get your hopes up,
recognize that this is
Chapter 11 bankruptcy.
A chapter 11 bankruptcy is
a kind of reorganization
that attempts to pay off the creditors
and allow the company or firm to continue
as a going forward concern.
Now, that being said, it can be used
as a potential shield against litigation,
or at least to delay litigation
and the NRA has filed
for bankruptcy in Texas
probably seeking a more favorable venue
than New York where they're
currently being sued
by Attorney General Tish James
who has vowed to basically
sue them out of existence,
but it will be interesting
to see what happens here,
because the NRA is made up of
many different organizations,
one of which the original
is chartered in New York,
but those assets may be folded into
some of the other NRA related affiliates.
So the NRA is not going
anywhere at the moment.
So stay tuned for more legal analysis
and I'll see you in court.